the thing that's really percolating for
me and a literary sense is just this the
way that this deep feeling of gloom
seems to have settled over us I'm really
interested in sort of collective mood
swings you know that the there's a kind
of giddiness you know in the 90s when
when that calm boom was happening and
there was just a sense that you know
America could do anything in that you
know everybody could get rich and
obviously you know September 11 created
a whole other you know collective mood
swing then we and we've been on a kind
of you know things have been steadily
darkening I think but but boy this last
crash just you could just feel it
there's a kind of pall over us and I
think a lot of ideas that people have
been living with for a long time or are
looking like the you know they were
misconceptions and feel almost a kind of
mood of fear and you know close to grief
for for all those hopes that we had and
then the sense that that all sorts of
things were possible and and it may be
exaggerated and we may bounce back from
this and we may forget all about it but
right now I'm just sensing a kind of
very dark mood and a kind of almost like
a bet you know is slightly apocalyptic
moved in America right now and that's
something I've been thinking about and
I'm trying to figure out if there's some
way to to work with that I know they've
been a lot of it a lot of riders doing
apocalyptic fiction I think Cormac
McCarthy's the road was a really
interesting sort of prophetic book
you know it obviously did dealt with a
kind of nuclear or he didn't specify
what it was it's not so much i'm not
feeling a sort of you know Cold War
nuclear war kind of darkness but just a
sense that our way of life isn't what we
thought it was or can't be what we
expected it to be and so what's left
nightly that could lead to some really
interesting changes you know the idea
that Americans were going to change
voluntarily because it made sense to say
drive smaller cars or consume less
that's just not how we work you know it
we really have to be forced into
changing but I have a feeling that we
are being forced into changing that
could be there could be some
opportunities in that but in the
meantime there's just a pretty dark
sense of our horizons now